[Music]
all right well the music turned off and
that guy told me that I'm supposed to
come up on stage now so let's have a
talk about security yay congratulations
everyone you made it it's the last day
the conference when I think about the
kind of topics I want to hear about when
it's the last day of a conference I'm
tired of and having a good time I just
had lunch I'm warm full belly security
in the cloud is not exactly the most
exciting thing in the world to everyone
so I want to thank you I'll do my best
not to put you to sleep we're gonna have
some fun today we're gonna look at a
couple of demos talk about some problems
and hopefully make some make some bad
decisions along the way because that's
where we actually learn our lessons
before we get it all into that my name
is Justin Beckwith I'm an engineering
manager at Google a lot of the demos
that we're gonna look at today you're
gonna be able to find on github if you
want to reach out to me or get into
contact with any of the teams that make
the cool products I'm going to talk
about today then all my contact
information is there feel free to reach
out for those of us in the information
security field this has been kind of a
rough year it's been a hard year to
watch we've seen multiple high profile
breaches I'm gonna do not do those
companies the disservice of putting
their their logos here or any of the
news clippings but we've seen several
incidents where companies were careless
with their customers data this is a real
problem and the worst part is it's
something that we tend to think as
engineers or as IT admins or sis admins
we tend to think that it's a problem
that we can just solve with technology
there's a specific product that can help
us lock it down this way there's a
specific thing that we can use here well
in some cases that's true the truth is
this is really a consumer trust problem
because the moment that we take on a
customer's data and they've made the
relationship with us they've trusted us
with that data and then we lose it we
have a breach that relationship
oftentimes is impossible to repair it's
not something that we as business owners
can ever get back the impact globally
according to a recent report of an
average data breach is about four
million dollars now this is average
going anywhere from you know a small
sick
breach which no one likes to think any
of them are a small deal all the way up
to something like what happened with
Equifax where the effects are going to
ripple for for quite some time and
that's not anything that any of us want
on our watch it's not something anybody
wants to expose their customers to the
truth is security information security
in the cloud with user data this is a
business problem once that trust is lost
it's not coming back
not easily we need 10 positive
interactions to make up for one negative
interaction and if you lose someone's
customer data and they they they lose
their social security number and have
identity fraud then well you know it's
gonna take maybe more than 10 good
interactions but good news there are no
magic bullets there's not one thing
that's going to fix this for us so if
anyone's trying to sell you one thing
that's going to fix security in the
cloud
you probably shouldn't buy from them
nothing is going to make you a hundred
percent secure but what we can do is we
can identify the most common risk
factors the highest risk factors and we
can we can reduce that risk we can
mitigate the highest risk factors and
that's largely what we're gonna talk
about today we're gonna be taking a look
at preventing and mitigating known
vulnerabilities in our software stack
through containers through virtual
machines through the software that we're
actually running inside of our
applications and find what are some of
the most common ways that they can be
compromised and how can we mitigate that
how can we reduce the surface area for
the potential attack when I talk about
vulnerability protection I like to think
about this in three different buckets
the first place we're not a lot of
people really think about is that code
time increasingly the software that
we're building or that our software
teams are building are comprised of
third-party components it's not like it
used to be where you would have one
giant standard library you'd build your
application you write a hundred percent
of the code and you know exactly what's
in there how many of us here are using
something like NPM maven pip go go get
any go get packages composer there's you
know one of these every language
ecosystem has a third-party ecosystem
that increasingly has become critical to
the success of our software so for all
those people that raise hands how many
of you read over every line of code that
you're importing into your application
that's amazing I want to talk I want to
know how to scale that
we need tools we need better tools to
tell us yes we want to enable our
developers to be successful and go build
great things and use what's out there in
the community at the same time we need
to make sure that there are no known
vulnerabilities and that honestly in a
lot of cases that we have the
appropriate licenses in place because it
becomes not just a security issue but a
compliance issue as well the next phase
of vulnerability prevention comes at
Build time and this is where if you're a
containerized organization there are a
lot of great options for you out there
because we've started to take what used
to be purely at the deployment time in
the infrastructure stage and we can now
pull that all the way back into our
build time processes I want to know what
operating system are we using which
distribution which version what packages
are installed can I compare those
packages against the list of known
vulnerabilities and then lastly once I
have all that information about the
build can I give it you know in my CI
system the good old thumbs up or the you
know thumbs down and that brings me to
the last part of vulnerability
prevention deployment time so you've
built your container you've built your
application binary you're ready to send
it into production what are we doing at
prod time to make sure that it's done
all that other checks and all those
other things we said it would do how do
I know that there are no third-party
third-party packages vulnerabilities how
do I know that we did a scan how do I
know that my build system is the one
that produced to that build how do I
know this isn't just an arbitrary binary
that one of my developers made on their
local machine who possibly is
disgruntled or they had an attack on
their their desktop these are all
questions we need to think about it each
face or a software development lifecycle
process to be able to reduce that search
area for surface area of attacks today
we're largely going to be talking about
build time and deployments at the time
as it relates to containers and
kubernetes so lastly security it's easy
to say oh this company had a huge breach
they were negligent individuals were
negligent it tends not to be a people
problem it's not that any one person
wasn't doing their job it tends to be a
process problem we need to ask the
questions how do we know our software is
secure how do we know it's verified in
the build and then how do we know if
they're any new ones once it's already
in production it's not enough just to
stop vulnerabilities from getting into
production we have to react after the
there and for each of these phases we
need to have a well-defined process and
a set of tools that helps us commit to
that process and that's what we're going
to talk about today
it's a process problem and I'm go in the
wrong direction let's go this way
all right so now we're so now we've done
a lot of a lot of talking a lot of
talking I want to show how some
potentially benign looking applications
can actually expose pretty significant
holes that allow you to take down an app
so we're going to talk about my terrible
horrible no good very bad day this is a
fictitious story this did not actually
happen any similary to any production
service living or dead is immediately
coincidental all right so a fairly
typical application architecture that
you might find in google cloud is gonna
be run on top of kubernetes kubernetes
engine in my case I have a front-end
service that's individually scalable I
have a back-end service that's scalable
the two are connected via G RPC we have
the cloud vision API have cloud storage
for files I have some other random API
here often the distance that I'm calling
but in terms of a tick typical business
application that's being built in a
containerized workflow this this is it
and this is the type of app that we're
gonna look at and how I actually
personally made some pretty bad mistakes
when I built the app that we're gonna we
were gonna see and of course you know my
boss is over there saying he totally
trusts me
he's positive I'm gonna build this
mission-critical app and it completely
won't have 100 vulnerabilities it'll
tank the business I appreciate his
confidence in me I don't know if he's
out there or not and so our totally
mission critical business application is
gonna be about cats this is actually my
cat that's boo boo bad kitty and can we
move over to the demo it's gonna look
action don't know if it to the demo
because it looks exactly the same as the
slide that's interesting but I can see
my mouse moving around so I feel pretty
good so what this mission critical
business application does is it's
actually going out to Reddit it's
downloading images from our /aw which is
cute animal pictures if you've never
seen it and then it's categorizing them
into two buckets on the Left we have
cats and on the right we have dogs and
it's using the cloud vision API to
figure that out and sort it all together
so it looks like the dogs are out to a
bit of an early lead we have the
with the watermelon there are puppies
cats are fallen a little bit literal box
of cats that's just going to count as
one like I said here this is very
important to the business because we're
trying to make people productive
I need cute pictures of animals to stay
happy if I'm not happy I'm not
productive therefore business-critical
we have the lake at and look at that
dogs win that was half-hearted come on
let's hear it for dogs fun fact I wrote
this app three years ago dogs always win
it's the weirdest thing
and I actually have years of data and
bigquery to prove it if anybody's
interested all right let's go back to
the slides actually so this is a pretty
simple application all this is really
doing for the front end for the front
end container it's using an
out-of-the-box nodejs container that I
found on docker hub I went on docker hub
I searched for one it looked fine I used
it I expect yeah exactly this is three
years ago give me a break I exposed a
port on it in ago and I and I run the
final and I run the final command so
knowing what I know now that I've been
at Google for a while and kind of going
back and trying to fix that it just so
happens that the container I had used
had a couple of couple of minor
vulnerabilities in the distribution of
Debbie and it was using using a version
of nodejs that is completely out of
support not receiving any security
updates
none of the third-party components of
the MPM models I was using or getting
patched and it's just been kind of
hanging around so let's go over to a
demo and see what we can do this is
always fun can we go to the demo yay
there we go alright so this is the
source and this particular version of
Debian unpatched was susceptible to a
neat little drip attack so I can run
attack got Sh we're going to wait
hopefully this is not a problem for the
Wi-Fi we're going to we're going to open
a bunch of HTTP connections but we're
not gonna send data we're just a slowly
drip drip drip bits of data with a bunch
of open connections let it warm up
alright so we did it
so I'm going to open a new tab and let's
see if I go to cats touch a back with
comm I've never given a demo where the
point was for the demo not to work this
is new for me we did it I was able with
a simple bash script to take down my own
site thank you
oh yes I mean this conference Wi-Fi is
terrible it's always causing problems so
let's cancel that out we're gonna give
it a minute let my service breathe it's
on kubernetes so the good news is that
after everything falls down the pods
will probably restart and if the attack
has stopped and I'm back all right so
that's can we go back to the deck so
that's not good that is very bad this is
not what we want to have happening for
any of the applications that we are
responsible for running so could this
how could this have been avoided to help
avoid issues like this that's why Google
is working on the container registry
vulnerability scanner say that three
times fast container registry
availability scanner I'm not gonna try
now the vulnerability scanner it will
detect vulnerabilities before deploying
to production today the types of
vulnerabilities for detecting are in
operating systems operating system
packages we have an eye towards the code
and third-party ecosystem that we
discussed we give you notifications when
we find those in a variety of ways that
we're gonna look through demos of today
supports Debian Ubuntu and Alpine with
red hat with a red hat linux and CentOS
on the way integrates with existing
tools and workflows and we see a couple
examples of glue how we can do that and
it's currently available in alpha
there's actually gonna be a link at the
end of the deck of how y'all can go sign
up and try it out if you'd like to so
enough enough jibber-jabber let's go
take a look at the demo machine again
alright so we talked about the image I
deployed with a whole bunch of
vulnerabilities I'm gonna go over to the
google cloud developer console this is
my cloud cats project and what we're
gonna see is a little bit of interesting
new UI that pops up in a container
registry UI
for those of you who aren't aware
container registry is google's
high-performance secure place to store
all of your docker container images and
that's what I'm using for my for this
app I'm under the CC web directory and
you can see all of the images that I all
of the tags that have pushed all the
shah's have pushed for this particular
container and you can see here 623
discovered vulnerabilities that that's a
big number but what does it actually
mean and so I'm gonna dive in one level
deeper and we're gonna take a look
within that 10 critical as rated by the
CBS s score 100 high 417 medium and you
can read the numbers on and on so we're
gonna give you a detail for each of the
vulnerabilities that we were able to
just that we were able to discover
inside of the container how critical it
is if there's a fix available the
package and then lastly almost most
importantly a link out to the CBE
documents so that you can read what
happened how to patch it what is the
actual risk so let's take a look at one
of these I'm gonna click on getting four
four four eight one of my favorites and
we can see this is a bug inside of Lib
XML - it looks like it was vulnerable in
Debbie and Jessie which for those of you
who follow along with Debian there's a
Jessie stretch and then the latest is
Buster but I don't think it's LTS yet
stretch I'm pretty sure is the latest
LTS but Jessie is kind of getting
getting a little bit long in the tooth
so it looks like I must be running on it
just a completely old version of Debian
is probably what's going on here but
let's take a look at a few of the other
ones when you look through the package
names it's not just Linux or it's not
just gee Lib see image magic math
doesn't use image magic why am I getting
a vulnerability and image magic for
something I don't even use and the more
you go through here the more you start
to find this so I'm gonna go through
I'll find OpenSSH I probably need that
sequel light I'm definitely not using
sequel lights Lib VPX
don't know what that does might be
important and so it starts to become
very clear is that I've got a collection
of problems that are starting to pile up
here that are leading to this huge
surface area of attack so if we go back
to the deck
how do we actually go and fix all these
problems with 623 vulnerabilities you
can't just take them one by one it turns
out that most of these fixes fall into a
set of three common buckets the first
bucket is you know install patches
easier said than done but this is
something that you need to do often you
have to do it daily and your docker
build files add the good old apt-get
update and apt-get upgrade commands or
for whatever distribution you use and
love most update them apply patches one
of the great things about the kubernetes
world is that it used to be with virtual
machines planning patch x was actually
kind of hard we may have to take the
product out of production doing them
batch over time and handling all the
restarts was difficult with a
containerized infrastructure there are
all kinds of tools built into kubernetes
to help us handle this and to make it
easier so that's kind of the first
bucket the second bucket is removing the
packages you're not actually using a
stock a Debian or a boon to operating
system comes with a mountain of stuff
that makes it great for perform for
portability most applications most of
the time can run on an out-of-the-box
installation of Debian or a boon too but
the cost of that is that it's got a ton
of packages you probably don't need for
your application and you really have to
go in and ask the question how many of
those did you really need and can you
remove them and lastly in kind of the
most extreme case which we're gonna take
a look at next is moving to a different
distribution kind of now that we've
started to understand the the
ramifications of using these giant
operating systems we've started look at
things like alpine debian slim smaller
distros less attacks attack surface area
so let's give it a try and let's
actually go deploy see what it's like to
deploy a more secure container image
alright so I'm over here in my cloud
cats application I'm gonna go into the
web tier and you can see here I've got a
docker file nothing too fancy
as I mentioned node 4 so let's go ahead
and let's upgrade this running VI on
stage what could possibly go wrong
all right so instead of node four I
happen to know that ten is the latest
version that's available so let's do
that and instead of Debian the full
Debian package I'm also gonna tell it I
happen to know that there is an Alpine
package out there Alpine is a much
smaller distribution supports a very
tiny subset of packages but often just
works
oops okay see I got what I deserved I
got fancy alright so just as an example
I'm going to do a docker build example
build the directory just to make sure
that everything works alright and it
looks like it builds and then I'm gonna
run I have an update script that does
the build pushes it to container
registry and actually replaces the image
of my production service out of sheer
laziness and a lack of desire to type
out the full docker push command I'm
just going to run that bash script and
we're building again we have cloud cats
most of the layers in GC are already
exist and we're going off and we've just
rolled the whole thing out so now the
new the new version is rolled out and
available on cats dot J Beckwith comm
let's go take a look at what's going on
behind the scenes now so we can see we
have an image we just uploaded now first
thing to take into account is AIDS done
scanning that was pretty fast we went
from an image that was 300 megabytes
down to an image that's 75 mega bytes
with the move from Debian over to alpine
and most importantly I'm not going to
claim there are no vulnerabilities
because that would be foolhardy there
were none found against the known list
of vulnerabilities in that version of
Alpine that version of node fully
patched so we went from something that
had 623 vulnerabilities by paying just a
little bit more attention it's what we
used is the base of our docker image and
making sure it was something we
understood and where it came from
we've made it that much we've reduced
the attack surface that much all right
let's go back to the deck
so it's all well and good that we fixed
it but this isn't really a good process
relying on me to go mill around inside
of the container registry you I
discovered that there are
vulnerabilities react to it and then
just kind of hope it doesn't happen
again this is this is not a strategy for
success so the next thing we're going to
talk about is getting a good CI Siddhi
process that uses that uses these tools
and takes them into account every time
that we're shipping code or we're
developing an application we go through
this natural evolution and you'll see
slides like this you've probably seen
them all through the week with the cloud
build announcement and the other things
that we've been working on we go from
code we build we test and then go into
production and then each step along the
way we want to be able to make the right
kinds of checks to make sure that we're
not making mistakes
this is where the container analysis API
that we have which is part of our
container scanning infrastructure really
becomes helpful when you do the build we
can check what what vulnerabilities are
available in this package we can write
what's called an attestation or a sort
of statement of support saying that
during the build we checked I'm giving
it a stamp of approval this has been
scanned when we run the test same thing
and then lastly a deploy time we want to
ask again ask that question it's great
that you're trying to deploy a container
who built it can you verify that it was
my build system can the build system
verify there were no known
vulnerabilities can it verify that all
the tests pass can you verify any other
sorts of things that are critical for my
business does it have the right licenses
what promises can I make and what
infrastructure is in place to help me
make all of those checks before I let
this thing into my production kubernetes
cluster so that's all well and good we
can now test you know going on we have a
better process what do we do when a new
vulnerability is discovered so we have a
couple of things to help make this
easier first we use what's called the
the activity stream inside of the cloud
developer console you'll get a
notification and this is actually if
you're enrolled inside of the Alpha then
you'll get this today and every time a
new vulnerability is discovered you can
actually click on that little bell
little show little alert with a number
and you can go in dig deep get
information use the UI that we talked
about
the other thing you can configure are
email notifications so I get a daily
rule up that has all of these security
vulnerabilities that are found I say all
of traditionally I go fix them now and
lets me know if there's something that I
need to work on if you use email as your
workflow tool the one that we don't talk
a lot about which I don't think many
people actually know we have is we have
a mobile application there's an Android
app that works fantastic and you can
actually configure that to get push
notifications so if someone in your team
pushes something that has a
vulnerability if it got past all these
other controls you can actually get a
push notification letting you know you
have a vulnerable image sitting out
there in production and then lastly like
everything that we released from Google
cloud there is if there is a fully
featured API now the fully featured API
lets you do your typical crud operations
you can create new occurrences create
notes read all the information you can
do that on a loop but the one that we're
gonna look at next is our pub/sub API
now what's cool about this is with
pub/sub we'll publish a new event every
time a new vulnerability is found and
then you can use that to integrate it
into any workflow any tool that you want
to use let's take a look at how I
actually did this over over on the
desktop all right so I'm going to go
over to cloud functions so cloud
functions isn't easy to use functions as
a service product and essentially the
idea is you can have very simple hooks
to execute small discrete pieces of code
they've got a couple of really cool
launches this week that you should
probably go check out one of the
features of it that I like the most is
that you can directly trigger an event
based off of something coming into
pub/sub and when you come over here
you'll see all of the the potential
trigger type instead of an HTTP endpoint
I'm gonna look for a cloud pub/sub
endpoint and then it'll just list all of
the topics that have already been
created since we're in alpha right now
it's called resource resource notes
occurrences v1 alpha one so yeah I
expect that you'll all remember that and
be able to go type it after this but it
gives you the drop-down list and what's
cool is now that I have those events now
every time that we get a new donor
ability discovered I can go into here
write some JavaScript and
react to it I'm not gonna make you
suffer me writing JavaScript on stage
there are other talks you can watch me
do that and people suffer through it but
I've already created a trigger that
actually what goes and does this let's
take a peek so what I decided that I
wanted to see happen is I have this code
in a and it happens to be in a public
github repository don't post your
security vulnerabilities to a public
github repository this is just for demo
purposes only but what I'm doing is I'm
gonna use the octo kit the github API
every time there's a experts Nouveau new
vulnerability I'm going to authenticate
to github I'm gonna grab the message
that comes out and I'm gonna go create a
new github message so it'll just say new
vulnerability found let's see if it
worked
alright so here's the github repository
if you two want to be able to put dogs
against cats here it all is and we look
at issues okay I have 204 issues
probably stemming from some of the
previous images I had pushed you click
in and it'll give you kind of some of
the API information from here you could
use this to use the read API to go get
all the information you want so if you
wanted to integrate with your existing
bugs system if you wanted to integrate
with your existing alerting system if
you had special things that you had set
up that you wanted to use with
stackdriver
you can use this API and pub/sub and
cloud functions to easily kind of glue
it all together let's go back to the
deck
I'm taking this this time all right so
that I think that was the reacting the
new vulnerability is demo so lastly you
can find the vulnerability information
inside the developer console we talked
about using the mobile application and
push notifications we talked about
customizable API based workflows with
pub/sub and about cloud functions just
in general being really good glue for
these sorts of things especially when
pub/sub is involved now you may be
thinking this is great if you're a GCP
customer but what if you're just running
if you have kubernetes and you're
running it on premise or what if you
have kubernetes and you're running this
you're running this on another cloud
provider well what about what about open
source that's great
one of the projects that we have that
we've worked hand-in-hand with just a
whole bunch of other companies on
defining is called grow fast and grow
fayus I'm going to say the sentence and
open an artifact metadata API to audit
and govern yourself if supply chain what
the hell does that mean what that
actually means is that we have a
consistent way for vendors to tell us
what artifacts do we have in our build
system and running in production
what vulnerabilities are out there and
what auditability do we need to have and
so you probably don't just have Google
Cloud scanning your containers you might
have Aqua security you might have black
duck you might have twist lock you might
have any number of vendors that are
going and verifying different pieces of
information about your artifacts this is
an open API designed to be able to store
that information and there's a reference
implementation available on github
so the metadata types and providers they
grow and they change as we pick up new
companies and we work with them and they
ask to store different types of
information those standard has been
moving quickly we've had open open
contributions from J Frogg Red Hat IBM
Black Duck a lot of the companies that
we just talked about this wasn't done
just at Google this is something that we
did with the community you can get a
nice nice bit of visibility both in
terms of assets that are in your source
code control all the way through the
build system to production and it can be
used both in the cloud the container
analysis API we provide on Google Cloud
implements the graph a is to open API so
taking that and connecting it so it's
great we have this open API sort of
database artifact analysis thingy how do
we connect that to kubernetes it would
turn out that kubernetes has this really
cool feature called the admission
controller and essentially sits inside
in front of any command that's gonna be
run intercepts requests and says let's
you write a little hook of code the base
what is that yes this looks good or no
get out of here where this is really
great is for remember how we were
talking about checking to make sure that
there are no vulnerabilities and that
who built the container the kubernetes a
mission controller is how we can
actually go do that if you're looking
for tutorial on how to work with graffia
sand how to use that with and how to set
up your own instance of it there's a
great tutorial out there own github made
by Kelsey Hightower who spoke here this
morning I highly suggest to go walk
through that and check it out the next
thing that we're gonna talk about we
were able to store the data we have this
admission controller but you'd have to
do a lot of glue to kind of put the
pieces together we're also producing
kritis another open source project built
alongside Gro fayus that makes it easy
to take and and check assertions before
running your containers inside the
cluster so you can test assertions plug
directly into the existing admissions
controller check build provenance ensure
build scanning happen and also and
there's just a lot of neat little things
that you can do with it that it's very
easy to extend again open source again
available on github so let's say that we
wanted to take our cluster and we wanted
to lock it down say ok Justin he
deployed this thing with node.js for it
was terrible it had six
123 vulnerabilities I think was the
number I don't want to let anybody
deploy anything into my cluster if it
has vulnerabilities and so you can
create a configuration like this with
kritis that essentially says this is an
image security policy there are some
images I'm gonna tell you are just okay
there are but other than that I want to
make sure that you have a you do not
check in any containers that have a high
security vulnerability in it just will
not allow it but except for CVEs one two
and three our security team looked at
and they said those ones were fine so I
have this tight control over what I'm
allowed to push into my into my registry
and so let's actually take a look at how
this works and how you can try it today
every time back to the cat all right so
I have another Google cloud project over
here and we're looking at some of the
images I have in container registry
we're gonna dig down and I have this a
rather benign looking Java image that
has one critical vulnerability inside of
it and 31 others again the goal here was
to have a cluster where I don't let
anything like this with a high critical
vulnerability pass so I'm gonna activate
I'm going to use activate the cloud
shell if this is slow I will blame it on
the Wi-Fi weird dance all right so we're
going to go into here I'm gonna take a
deep look at the image and I need to
copy this I'm gonna get the full shot
and if we look in this directory here to
see that I have a pod dot yeah mol this
pod damo all it does it says this is the
name of the pod we're gonna run please
use please use this this image which
matches the one that we had pushed and
open up port 80 so let's go ahead and
let's try to start our pod on the
cluster I'm gonna do a cube CTL - eff
oopsy tail create - f pod animal and
pretty quickly it's going to try setting
that up it's gonna take a look at the
image it's going to take an
uncomfortable amount of time and then
it's going to reject my request to
create the pod and you can see here the
air that we're getting
the admission hook kritis foundation
hook denied the request because it found
violations based on our policy so now we
don't have to worry about who's
deploying one into our cluster we can
give tight controls on our cluster both
inside of google cloud and in our own
kubernetes / graffia / credits
deployment and lock it down and ensure
that we have a semi a more secure
environment let's go back to the deck so
what is the timeline on all of this I
mentioned that we're currently in alpha
all the features we saw today are
available and you can use them inside of
the alpha group it integrates with your
existing images that are pushed into GCR
so if you're an existing kubernetes or
existing container registered customer
we can actually turn this on and it all
just lights up today to get access you
can join the container analysis users
group we're going to share the link for
that in a moment
the things are working on what's coming
up in the works we had a lot of this we
wanted to get ready for this week it's
not far away it's coming very soon the
big one for me is support for Red Hat
Linux and CentOS cloud security command
center integration so kind of bring this
into the security control stuff that's
available the organization level and
plugging in all the policy and
notification management there and then
just general UI optimizations and and
bug fixes so wrapping this all to wrap
this all up security is hard any of us
that have worked in the field for awhile
know there's one thing that will fix it
there's no silver bullet but our
businesses depend on it we've tools
they're gonna help you get through this
we have the right CI CD offerings we
have the scanner we're doing all of this
in the open and we want to do it with
you and lastly if you want to join the
group please send your questions to
container analysis feedback at Google
comm one last one last last last thing
we actually released a new site today
cloud ragù comm slash containers slash
security that goes way more in depth on
everything I talked about today as long
as a variety of other topics extending
you know all the way out into the VM
image to network security - I am - all
those all those other pieces that we
need to think about really recommend
folks to go give this a look and send us
feedback because we're really excited
about it
and thanks
[Applause]
[Music]